free ps4 to ps5 upgrades for certain
games microsoft clarifies the xbox
series s backwards compatibility
and new monster hunter games are on the
way i'm lucy and these are the biggest
gaming news stories
for thursday september 17.
yep ps5 pre-orders were a complete mess
yesterday let me know if you managed to
snag one
but good news if you didn't manage to
grab one or you're going to be sticking
with playstation 4 for a little bit
longer
some ps4 ps5 cross gen games will be
including
free upgrades from ps4 to ps5 it
includes ps5 launch titles spider-man
miles morales and sac boys big adventure
as well as horizon forbidden west if you
buy the digital ps4 version you can
download the digital ps5 version
and if you buy the ps4 disk you can
insert it into the ps5 disk drive
but this does mean that you can't get
the upgrade if you buy the ps4 disk
but then buy the all digital ps5 without
the disk drive
yes it sounds a little bit confusing but
for all of the info head over to
gamespot.com or we have a video
right here on our youtube channel and
speaking of next gen upgrades
microsoft has clarified how the xbox
series s backwards compatibility is
going to work
the short version is that the series x
runs the xbox series
s versions of games then adds
enhancements from there
the series s will run those games at 144
p and 60 frames per second
with additional features like improved
textures higher and more consistent
frame rates
hdr and faster low times the series s
can run games at 4k
if a developer chooses to do so but
that's not microsoft's goal with the
console
native 4k is the target for the series x
pre-orders for the series x and series s
go live on the 22nd
and let's hope we just don't go through
what we went through with sony
[Music]
nintendo held a mini direct this morning
and announced two
new monster hunter games first is
monster hunter
rise which is a new mainline monster
hunter game the trailer showed off some
new
big monsters including the magnamolo
which seems to be the big bad of the
game
there are cat and dog companions too and
the game will have its own amiibo
figures of the companions
and the magnamello monster hunter rise
will launch on switch on march 26th
2021 the second game is monster hunter
stories two
wings of ruin this is a sequel to the
3ds spin-off with the same
cel-shaded art style you play as a
monster rider who actually rides
on the back of a monster companion
there's no really date for this one just
yet but it's slated for summer
2021 yes it's a sequel to the 3ds game
but it's coming to switch because the
3ds
is officially being discontinued and
it's the whole family
the 3ds new 3ds and 2ds join us tomorrow
for another episode of generation next
our weekly show all about the new
consoles
this week we're going to be asking the
question did sony do
enough at their showcase and of course
talk a little bit about all the
rigmarole
around trying to pre-order a playstation
5. i'm on twitter at lucy james games
and i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you